INSTRUCTOR: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back.
So in today's video,
we're going to be covering
a topic that, we're sticking
with this theme of web
deployment, web
development in the cloud,
this is one of those tools that
you just kind of absolutely
need.
Some of you might have
been already exposed to it,
but hopefully you'll
still learn something new.
And if you haven't
been exposed to it,
pay attention because this
is one of those skills
that we constantly get feedback,
not only from our past students
or employers, but
also just in general,
our personal experiences, right.
We're going to be talking
about Git and GitHub today
specifically.
And this is just, again,
one of those skills
that you don't
often see in school
but is becoming absolutely
critical in the working world.
So to explain broadly what
that is, you all have now
probably taken either Data 3500,
or maybe some other programming
class.
Or even in this
class, you've seen
that we've started to do a
little bit of code development,
right?
When we've deployed
our websites,
we've had code that
underlies that.
As you might expect, very
few companies or websites
are built by a single person.
So that begs the question
almost immediately is,
how do you manage this
interactive collaborative work
in a coding environment?
And Git has become kind of the
de facto tool in this space.
So Git, G-I-T, that is
the underlying software.
It is a version control
system, that would
be the formal definition of it.
Version control in
the sense that, hey, I
have one version of the code.
I write my initial code, it
goes up there on the website,
or goes live wherever
it is, and then
I might make a change
to it, therefore, there
is a new version of it.
Similarly, I might
have a coworker
that makes a change to it, that
is a different version of it.
So Git is software
that allows us
to manage kind of the
interaction of these two things.
How do we make sure that they
work together effectively?
How do we make
sure that we don't
overwrite each other's work?
And if we need to roll back
to previous code, where
maybe like the new feature we've
implemented breaks everything,
how can we roll back
to a point where
we knew things were stable?
So that's what Git does.
And then GitHub, G-I-T
hub, is a website
where you can go online and
push your code repositories.
So there's a bunch of other
platforms to do this on.
You'll see GitLab.
Atlassian has their suite of
tools around this as well.
But really, most of them are
using Git under the hood,
though there do
exist other ones.
It's just that Git
is the most famous,
and GitHub is arguably
the most popular,
mostly because it has wide
support across the open source
community.
And it's usually more user
facing as opposed to public
facing-- or private within
internal to a company facing.
Though they do have kind of
enterprise versions as well.
So that's what we're going
to be covering today.
If you can't tell as well,
I'm on an EC2 instance,
so feel free to get that
started up while I'm just
talking some more.
But to keep highlighting
a few other things
that we want to be
able to do with this.
Obviously, like I said,
version control is key.
Collaboration, not only
just with somebody else,
but just across a broader team.
How do you collaborate broadly?
Git will enable us to do that.
We won't talk about it
a ton in this course,
but this is a core way
that a lot of companies
operate is via, you'll
see the acronym CI/CD
is continuous integration,
continuous deployment.
This idea that you will always
have a version of the website
live, and you need to
have a pipeline in place,
a CI/CD pipeline in place such
that I can seamlessly basically
commit or submit new
code to our website.
And that is automatically tested
and built into the website,
and deployed live so that
we don't have to ever take
the website down basically.
And then, finally,
as well, and we'll
use this in a future lecture
when we talk about deployment,
plenty of platforms use
this kind of framework.
We've talked about
infrastructure as software,
but this is more of--
or infrastructure as a service.
Sorry.
That IaaS acronym.
You'll also sometimes
see this IAC acronym,
that is infrastructure as code.
And that just says, hey,
basically, all we need to do
is manage our Git repositories.
That's what our code bases
are called, is repositories.
We just manage our
Git repositories,
and then everything
else is handled, right?
So I just deploy my code
to my Git repository,
and then my website is
live and maintained.
So given that as kind
of our backing for this.
Again, I'm assuming you got
your EC2 instance launched now.
Now we're going to move toward
testing this out, building out
some of these capabilities.
So first order of
business is just
getting Git installed
on our EC2 instance.
Like I said, this Git
is just the software
for version control.
We can have any
number of interfaces
to this, whether
that means we just
use the kind of
command line here
or if we actually use
some sort of interactive,
kind of graphical
user interface, where
we can click and drag and
do all that good stuff.
So we're unsurprisingly going
to do everything via the command
line, but just know
that there are options.
So feel free to look at,
for your specific operating
system, whether it be
Windows, or Mac, at what some
of the different interfaces are.
But for Linux, it's pretty easy.
First we're going to do
our usual sudo apt update
-y to update our library
of packages here.
And then once we do
that, we are going
to install the Git
software itself, too.
So we'll do, and I hope-- let
me double check, make sure
on my video side of things.
Yeah, it's still visible.
I'll actually do this.
We're going to use GitHub
in a little bit anyways.
So I'll just slide this over, so
we're kind of on a split screen
mode here, and I ensure
that I never cover up
the code base itself.
So we'll come back to the
right side of the screen.
In a little bit.
But for now we're just going to
say, OK, sudo apt install Git.
And if that worked,
you can check
by just running Git
and then --version,
and that should show you what
version of Git you're on.
In this case, I'm on 2.34.1.
Though, again, whatever
version installed for you
is perfectly fine.
Now common practice is to set
up your configuration of this.
That is to say, when
I'm submitting code,
we want to know who the person
is that's submitting code.
How do I ensure that I
can get a hold of them
if I need to know
what changes they made
or why they did certain things?
So you can do Git config
--global user.name
and then space,
and then your name.
Oops.
Of course, I have
to type this, right?
Let me slide this
up a little bit.
That's what I'm blocking
myself from seeing this.
There we go.
Now should be a little easier.
There we go, global
user.name and Sharad.
And then we're going to
do the same thing, git
config global user.email, and
then I'll do my email address.
And again, we're not doing
any sort of logging in
or we're not sharing our
information publicly.
All that's happening
is that anybody
else who is submitting
code to this repository
that we're going
to create, they're
going to see any
changes I made are
going to be labeled with my
username and my user email.
So the username
is arbitrary here.
It's not even saying necessarily
it's your GitHub username.
We're not to GitHub yet, right?
We're just focusing
on Git right now.
So before GitHub even existed,
Git was already there, right?
So this is already an
option to collaborate
with other developers.
You can check to see
configurations here.
Just doing git config --list.
And now we're set up to
create our first repository.
So I'm going to do mkdir.
Remember, that's make directory.
And it will be called
my-git-project.
Then I'll cd into there,
so cd into my-git-project.
And then to initialize
it as a Git repository,
basically saying to
tell Git that, hey, you
should start monitoring this
repository for any changes,
we'll call it git init,
for initialize, -b main,
where the -b main
sets the default
branch to the main branch.
And we'll talk about
branching in a second.
But the way to think
about it right now
is just that the
branch just defines
kind of what thread of work am
I doing, what am I building.
And the default is to
have a main branch that
is kind of the live or working
version of the application,
ideally.
That way, anything
new that's developed
has to get merged
into the main branch.
But again, we'll
come back to that.
So first, let's actually
just create a file in here.
So I'll do nano, and
we'll call the file,
we'll just make a readme.
And we'll make it a
markdown file, so .md.
And a markdown file, if
you're not familiar with that,
is just a special file type that
is often used for text files.
And in this case, you can
use special characters,
like this hash mark
here, we'll do a header.
So we're just making the
title of this my-git-project.
So we'll save that.
And now we have to go through
what I kind of treat as the--
or part of the default loop
for tracking changes or pushing
changes to your repository.
So first thing I usually
do is I run git status.
That tells me what
branch I'm on,
do I have any commits that
have been submitted yet,
and importantly, are there any
untracked files or changes will
also show up show up here too.
To add something to a
track-- to be a tracked file,
we run git add, and
you can either specify
the specific files name.
Or if you've made
a bunch of changes,
there's a bunch of new files, a
shortcut is to just say git add
and then period, and that'll
add everything that's untracked
or any new changes to
just being tracked.
Or-- yeah, to being monitored.
So now, after I've run
the git add everything,
and I run git status,
you can see now
that we have no
commits still, but we
have some changes that are
kind of staged to be committed.
And then to commit it, we
just run git commit /m.
And we'll just say
initial commit,
because this is
our first commit.
So the way to think about
this is what we've done so far
is we've said, hey,
we've made some change.
We need to be watching this
change, monitoring this change.
And now I'm committing
this change to saying,
hey, this is a new change
that has been made.
But again, recognize that this
is all just still isolated
to my local repository.
Or this is only on this
machine, on this EC2 instance.
It's not accessible
anywhere else.
Now what we want to
do is push that up
to our remote repository.
Our remote repository
is going to be GitHub.
We're going to use GitHub as the
place to push all our code to.
So that way anybody
can interact with it.
So one of the first
things you need to do
is come to github.com and
just create an account
if you don't already have one.
If you do have one,
just log in to it.
And so, yeah, feel free to pause
it if you're in that moment
right now, just kind of waiting
for that to create your account.
Once you've created
your account, though,
what I want you to do is
click on your little icon
on the top right here and
scroll down, click Settings.
And then if you scroll to
the very bottom of settings
here and click
developer settings,
you can click Personal access
tokens, Tokens classic.
And then, we're going to
generate a new token up here
on the top right, and
Generate new token classic.
So personal access tokens are
basically kind of secure way
to interact with our repository
from a remote machine.
Basically, it's kind
of like our secret keys
that we've had before
where it says, hey,
I have to have this secret
key to be able to interact
with the remote repository.
If you don't have one of these,
you won't be able to do it.
So we can call us
whatever we want to.
I'll call mine
temporarytoken, because I'm
going to delete it
basically immediately.
I'm going to set the
expiration for seven days.
But note that, again, the
expiration is, treat this
as another kind of
security protocol,
is to say that I will
set a amount of time
that I want this token
to be viable for.
And then, after
that point, it is
going to be basically just
an expired token, right?
I won't be able to
use it for validation
of my personal profile.
The reason we do
this is that it's
kind of the same as
changing a password.
After a certain amount of
time, just from a security
perspective, it's
probably better
to just revoke
that token's access
and then create a new
one, just to make sure
that you're staying
relevant with it
and you don't have anything
that's kind of lingering
around unnecessarily.
So 7 days, 30 days, 60 days, 90
days, whatever you want to do.
We're just doing this for now.
And you'll have
assignments where
you'll need to push
to GitHub, so you're
welcome to do it for longer.
But again, no expiration.
It's going to probably
flag you, yeah.
And say, hey, this isn't
very secure to do this.
So you probably
shouldn't do that.
For right now.
I'm going to set mine to 7.
And then you need to
basically just specify
what it has access to.
And for right now,
we really just need
to have access over
our repositories.
So I'll just give it
permissions to the repos.
And then everything else, I'm
just going to leave blank.
And then click Generate token.
Now on this page,
you'll see this
is your secret token, your
personal access token.
Again, this is a private thing.
Obviously, mine, you
guys can see it here.
So that's not very secure.
But I'm obviously
also, first off,
going to delete this
once I'm done using it.
So it won't even
be viable anymore.
And also, in seven
days, no matter what,
the access, the permissions to
this are going to be revoked.
But you need to make sure
to copy this and store it
somewhere secure.
So wherever that
works for you, we're
going to need it
throughout this.
So I'm putting it in a little
notepad for myself temporarily,
while I'm using it.
But there are a whole suite of
more secure ways to do that.
But for now, again,
perfectly fine,
just put it in a little
notepad for yourself to access.
So we have that now.
So let's come back over and
click on the little icon
up here, the octocat
icon for GitHub.
And then we're going to
create a new repository.
And we're just going to name
this repository exactly what we
named our other-- or our local
repository, my-git-project.
And note that it needs to be
unique within your account.
So if it's-- it doesn't
have to be unique globally,
kind of like our S3 buckets do.
It just needs to be
unique within our account.
You can add a
description if you want.
You can specify whether your
repository is public or private.
Public is good if you want
to show this off to others.
Or, for example,
like when you guys
are going to need to send me
links to your repositories
to show me that
you completed work.
Easiest thing to do would
be to make it public,
so you don't have to
add me as a collaborator
or anything like that.
Though, note you
can still choose who
actually can commit code to it.
So it's not saying
I'm making it public
and anybody can change my code.
It's just saying it's
visible publicly.
And then private
is you basically
choose who can see and
commit to this repository.
So I'll just leave mine
as private for now.
So I don't have just a million
of these private repositories--
or default repositories created.
But leave everything
else here blank.
I'll explain what
these are, but we
don't want to change
anything here,
because we're pushing
all of our changes
from our local repository.
So don't add any of
these things here.
But in case you're
curious, the readme
file, we'll we just
created one, right?
We created one our
local repository.
So that's why we don't need one.
This is where you typically
will see the description of what
the project does.
So that's kind of a default one.
And that's why they have
it as an option here.
We'll talk about gitignores
in a future lecture,
but the short version
of it is that gitignore
is a special file that
says, hey, I maybe
want to ignore specific file
types within my repository.
Like never push those
up to my remote.
So if, for example, I
had a public repository
for some sort of
application I built
and I want it to be
visible to others
so they could build off of it or
kind of see the work I've done,
but it requires that I
have some secret tokens
to launch the website
on my local machine.
I can add my secret tokens
file to the gitignore
and say, hey, even though
this is in that repository,
never track it, never
push it to the repository.
And then finally is the license.
And this is basically
where you can
define who has what sort
of legal permissions
to interact with your code.
Even though oftentimes,
and actually many of these
are open source licenses
in the sense that they
say anybody can use this
code, certain licenses
will say, hey, you
can use this code,
but just not for
commercial purposes.
So this will be
relevant to you as you
start to build
products and companies,
and all sorts of things.
But for right now, that's
not a big deal for us.
So we'll click
Create repository.
And now we'll be
brought to this page.
So our repository
has been created.
We haven't put
anything in it yet,
but we have all
that set up there.
So now I'll slide this over
out the way for a little bit
so we can type again.
And so now we want to
push our local code up
to our remote repository.
So first thing I need
to do is come down here.
You'll see there's this line
here that gives us some tips,
actually, if we want to
create a new repository,
or if we want to
push an existing one.
We want to push an
existing one. so we'll
do copy this top line that
says git remote add origin,
and then it has a URL.
So that's saying, hey, we're
adding a remote repository.
And origin is just the standard
name for remote repository.
And it is going to be
pushing to this URL here,
so github.com/sharadkj/mid
git project.git.
And so that's
saying, hey, now we
have our local repository that
has a remote connection that
goes out to this
location, right,
to this specific
remote repository.
So hit Enter and it shouldn't
say anything if it worked.
And then, last step here,
we have-- if you remember,
if we do git status,
we have some--
or better statement, we
have committed our changes.
We have some initial--
we have initial file in there.
And so now we want to push this
up to our remote repository.
So we'll run git
push -u origin main.
And so this just sets the-- the
u sets the upstream reference
basically for any sort of future
pushes or pulls we're doing.
So we're saying git
push u origin main.
Then it's going to say,
give me your username.
And then, for the
password, we're
not going to put
our GitHub password,
we're going to paste that
personal access token that we
created and stored into a file.
So literally, just
copy and paste.
That's all I did
there, is Control-C
and Control-V. It doesn't show
anything when you paste it
there, so don't panic.
But if it showed like this
correctly or if it shows
basically branch main setup
to track remote manage main
from origin, all that good
stuff, then you're great.
If it threw an error of
any sort, easy enough.
Just rerun this command,
put in your username,
and put in the personal
access token as your password.
Now, if we come back over
here to our remote repository
and hit Refresh,
we see that we have
now a file, an initial
commit for that file.
That initial commit is the
readme that we created.
And we can see that it was 9
minutes ago that I pushed that,
or that I made that
initial commit.
It wasn't 9 minutes
ago that I pushed it
to the remote repository.
It was just 9 minutes ago
that I made that commit.
And so now you have a--
you've kind of seen the
workflow of making changes
to a Git repository.
The standard approach
is to say, hey, well,
maybe I want to add some
more text to my file here,
and this file could
be anything, right?
In our case, it's a readme.
But this could just
be your regular code
for your website, your
application, whatever it is.
So if I want to make a change,
maybe I say, OK, great,
Sharad is the coolest.
And that is going
to make it bold.
And then we'll
save those changes.
And if we do git
status again, you'll
see, OK, well, I modified this.
So I need to run git
add, and even tells you
that, use git add.
I'm going to add everything.
And then I'll do git
commit slash m, which
is how I can pass a message
along with the commit.
And I'll say, added important
details to the readme.
And again, this message
is just for reference
for other developers
that are working,
and they're like, oh, hey,
what did they do here?
I can see very easily
from this description.
So git add, git commit, and then
we'll run our git push origin
main, and then sharadkj.
And then I'll copy and paste
my personal access token.
And then I'll come over
here and I'll hit Refresh.
And boom, there you go.
Sharad is the coolest.
So that is, again, the general
workflow of using GitHub.
And honestly, like gets you
probably like 95% of the way
there with most things that
you'll do on a daily basis
on GitHub, whenever I'm
working on a project, some sort
of coding project, I usually
just have a terminal up
like this that in the
background after I've
made meaningful changes,
I've added some new feature
or element to this.
I'll run git add, git commit,
git push, git add, git commit,
git push.
I just keep iterating
through that.
It's kind of like saving
your work on your computer.
And the reason we want
to do this so frequently
is not to say every time I make
a single like code line or code
change, but every time I really
add some new element to my code,
it's great to have a check-in
to basically say like, hey, I
added a relevant new feature.
And so therefore, now I'm going
to push this code up there.
So that anybody can go in and
see all of my past changes,
right?
So I can go in here and
look at this last commit
and see, OK, that's
what was added there.
So now that we've
got that, we'll
have to understand
the other direction.
So we've pushed code.
Now we need to understand
what it means to pull code.
Now, this would
typically mean in a case
where I'm collaborating
with a friend or my company,
and somebody else has made
a change to this code base,
because we all have
access to push code here.
And I want to pull any changes.
So there's a remote repository
that's different than my local,
and I want to pull those
changes back to local.
So we're going to make an edit
to file up here on GitHub,
but this would
work just the same
if somebody else had
pushed their own code up
to our main branch here.
So to do that, first
thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to edit
this readme file.
So I'm just going to
this little Edit button,
and then come into this nice
little text editor and say,
Sharad is the coolest.
And will provide
some clarification.
Professor at USU.
I'm not biasing
you guys' opinions.
You can put whatever
you want here.
But either way, we'll
make that change.
We'll commit it up here.
And we'll say, update readme.md.
Great, we'll commit it
directly to the main branch.
Perfect.
Commit changes.
So now up here, on
our remote repository,
says Sharad is the
coolest professor at USU.
But if I look at my
readme down here,
it just says Sharad
is the coolest.
So again, we need
to pull that change
from our remote repository.
So, all we do, very
kind of expected,
is we do git pull origin main.
Same thing, username, grab
my personal access token
for the password.
And boom, we've now
pulled that locally.
And you can see, worked well.
One file was changed.
There was one insertion.
There was one deletion because
I think we removed the period.
But we can do now
cat and read me,
and we'll see that we
pulled those remote changes,
so pulled them from
our remote repository.
So I'll leave it there for now.
Yeah, we'll leave
it there for now.
And I'll introduce-- let
me see actually really
quick before I say that.
I don't want to make
this video too long, but.
I do think we have a
couple other things that we
want to add on to it.
So yeah, I will call
this for now here,
and then I'll
record another video
that includes some extra details
on branching and merging.
So that way, this one
video isn't crazy long.
But this should be enough
to get you started.
And in all honesty,
I think this is all,
we will need for the project.
So the next video will
just be a short explainer
for adding a few more
skills to our tool belt.
So thank you for watching.
And we'll pick up next time.